et maintenant
ouais c'est philippe bouvard
il va
et il ya quand même des langues est
simple franchement là il ya quand même
pris petit globe vous mesurer combien
plus sérieusement
écoutez un peu moins d'un mètre 70
mais bon les escabeaux sont pas faits
pour les chiens à tous les cas je suis
content de vous recevoir
j'ai passé tellement de samedi soir à
vous regarder mais je savais je savais
que j'étais regarder parce qu'ils
prendraient ma place un peu plus bien
alors philippe bouvard journaliste
écrivain polémiste homme de télévision
et de radio ou fait les grosses têtes
depuis 1977 et vous avez resigné pour
trois ans ce qui va vous mener en 2007
ce qui va faire 30 ans de grosses têtes
c'est énorme
alors on se demande philippe bouvard si
vous n'êtes pas immortel parce que là
vous êtes là de toute éternité
j'avoue je disparaîtrai vont vous alors
mais sagement si un jour vous deviez
disparaître ce que je ne veux pas croire
mais vous voudriez que ça se passe
comment voudrait mourir comment philippe
dans vos bras
ah oui votre dernier bon mot ça serait
quoi
or ça mais il faut se méfier des
derniers bons mots parce que souvent ils
n'ont pas été prononcés ils sont
totalement inventés mais j'ai déjà prévu
mon épitaphe où il y est passée comme
les autres le titre de libération
lendemain matin voudriez que ça soit
quoi bon choix du pont une étoile c'est
à la cérémonie publique
je pense que bon il ya peu pour ma
naissance il y avait pas grand monde
pour la fin je crois que enfin il faut
pas qu'ils aient plus de fluence et vous
voiler la même équipe a dû y avait quand
même des gens qui sont pas 10 pour la
peut-être laurent pour dire quelques
mots et carlos pour faire une blague
ils font actuellement ici philippe
bouvard pourrait-on cortège des mots
d'auteur cortège de chauffeurs de taxi
aussi non ah bah ça je leur dois
beaucoup vous imaginez quand même de
corbillard suivi par 12 mille taxi ah
oui et c'est en l'air du taurion
formidable la cérémonie briquet soit
retransmise sur rtl sur tf1 non je vous
dis la plus grande discrétion
mais surprise quand même ah oui parce
qu'il faut mais il ya toujours des frais
et gardiens pavillard les routes ça vous
plairait qu'on rebaptise bobino le grand
théâtre de bouvard
non non non non non non les batteries
comme ça ça et j'en ai beaucoup croquer
j'ai plus fin ouais ah oui voilà
c'est dommage parce qu'il avait pris
soin mais cela reste un formidable
donc sur votre pierres tombales ont
écrit j'en ai beaucoup ok je vais plus
et elle va comment va la belle paire de
l'offre en mousse et celle là d'abord
j'ai même pas si elle a jamais existé et
et puis vraiment j'en ai marre qu'on me
parle tout le temps de cette bonne femme
que j'ai jamais rencontré le pria d'agon
coutainville
elle est morte bonne réponse de facebook
un livre chez flammarion philippe qui
s'appelle des femmes et je vais le
résumé
voir
et la magie
voilà le résumé du livre de philippe
bouvard puisqu'il s'agit de 77 portraits
de femmes le sexe ford il vous le
véritable sexe fort ouais ouais c'est
mignon j'ai voulu non pas faire des 77
portraits de femmes célèbres noms 77
archétype de femmes
voilà voilà oui tout à fait car acte du
caractère un peu comme la bruyère on
pourrait dire alors il ya j'en ai pris
quelques unes comme ça il y alors à la
don juan
philippe dit personne ne saurait refuser
ses avances sans être suspecté
d'homosexualité ou d'impuissance
ah ben oui la fouille pas prêt mais il
est comme ça ah ben heureusement les
plus vils assélé sexuels alors que
l'hymne marseillais sexuelle vous
l'appelez la main courante
oui parce que chaque fois qu'on l'a
effleuré sens d'ailleurs malice dans la
rue ou dans un transport en commun elle
va rester plainte au commissariat alors
c'est le surnom que les les policiers
lui en donnent la main courante
aya grâce les sérieuses de régime elle
est comme ses vêtements elle craque de
temps en temps c'est vrai que c'est tout
ça est plein de plein de formules dont
vous avez le secret oui je pense que ce
sont des portraits très court donc il
faut qu'ils aient des formules c'est pas
un roman j'ai pas écrit la vie de 77
faire sinon enfin je serai pas fini
alors j'ai voulu que chacune soit cerné
par quelques traille qui corresponde à
la réalité
je voudrais que le lecteur ait des
lectrices éventuellement parce que c'est
pas fait pour un seul sexe recherche
dans cette typologie des personnages qui
correspondent à des gens de son
entourage puis monde se retrouva
évidemment il ya marie la servante
maîtresse et vous avez cette façon rien
elle portait la culotte parce qu'elle a
déçu l'enlever abbas à guîtres et
coutras mal il aurait pu ces gentils
jeunes gens ça pour un compliment et son
mec là couché sur son testament
un truc de la momie ça c'est moi sympa
squelette ambulant échapper des schémas
thorium des uv plus rien la phrase
tellement elle est déjà fripé j'adore
quand thierry blin unique
comment tu fais un dessin qui bouge
comme des vecteurs et philippe aussi la
ludivine l'animatrice va c'est pas un
archétype ça c'est clairement le
portrait de quelqu'un qu'on connaît en
l'air il ya plusieurs personnages non
accompagné le bouquet quand elle rompt
c'est surtout ne faut pas faire mentir
les journalistes qui ont annoncé sa
séparation
oh mais ça c'est valable pour beaucoup
de gens mais là on l'a reconnu la non
attendez la pitié non vous en connaissez
c'est pas tout à fait celle que vous
connaissait autres claire chazal et
madame ferrari quoi oui avec eux
un zèle rira et d'autres avec cela dit
leccia beau nom mais assez parlé de
chabwa
c'est ce que je demande alors ça c'est
alors la lasser des souvenirs personnels
si olga la masseuse perverse qui est
pleine de diplômés l'intention
thérapeutique mais enfin qui va jusqu'au
bout avec les mecs quoi c'est un
souvenir personnel ça non non mais vous
savez j'ai recueilli beaucoup de
confidences dans ma vie et ce temps en
temps j'ai été moi-même au charbon parce
qu'on peut pas croire tout ce que les
gens disent les sapins fort lien il y en
a une qui est l'archétype de toutes les
femmes pour moi c'est odile la madone du
train bleu qui se tape un mec dans le
train bleu pendant que sans son jules
l'attend sur le quai eygalières ça j'ai
connu et connu un oui c'est le mystère
des femmes ça c'est un truc que j'arrive
à jamais comprendre mais pas du tout
justement tu va célébrer comme ça non
n'est pas qu'elle soit
alors philippe anduze et que ces petits
portraits à la façon de la bruyère des
petites maximes qui deviendront
peut-être des citations
alors je vous faire une interview faire
valoir
alors comme je suis gentil respectueux
avec vous on va parler de vos citations
et je vous ai préparé des fiches avec
vos citations comme ça vous n'aurez même
pas besoin de vous en servir et vous
aller briller intensément quand vous
astique jeune fille
vous avez des questions ont valu
question c'est moi qui les posent et les
réponses c'est vous qui les fait voilà
c'est pas gentil ça pour vous c'est quoi
un artiste bah c'est quelqu'un qui a
réussi à transformer des défauts
caractériel en qualité professionnelle
même carlos oui etes-vous modeste oui
mais vous le savez la modestie cesse à
l'instant où on commence à en parler
pourquoi avez vous essayé de tricher
avec les impôts philippe jeu
les impôts ont été inventés pour tout le
monde n'est pas envie de réussir n'est
pas un peu nouvelle fois là on appelle
mauvaise foi les convictions d'autrui
qu'on ne partage pas vous pensez quoi
des hommes bah je m'étonne toujours que
des êtres également menacé par la mort
se fasse la vie aussi difficile alors
qu'il doit y avoir une solidarité de
condamner êtes vous un honnête homme qui
les beaux arts
l'honnêteté la seule méthode qui
permette d'escroquer plusieurs fois la
même personne
comment expliquez vous qu'on voit plus à
la télé c'est votre image
bon vous savez nous vivons dans un monde
où l'échec des autres devient plus
importante notre propre réussite
vous avez du talent selon vous non non
mais bon le talent consiste à dire les
mêmes bêtises que les hommes et plus
élégamment et j'ajouterais parce que
c'est un des principes fondamentaux de
la radio plus vite que les autres
avez vous peur de vieillir philippe
bouvard non je suis curieux de voir ce
que ça donne quoi que bon le matin je
suis pas toujours réjoui de ce que jouer
dans le miroir de ma salle de bains mais
je pense que les hommes sont comme les
vins
lorsqu'ils deviennent meilleurs en
vieillissant c'est qu'ils sont d'une
certaine qualité vous allez du caractère
non pas dans notre société on dit que
quelqu'un du caractère quand il accorde
plus d'importance à ses propres opinions
cause amis d'hôtes lui vous ai vécu
cinquante ans avec la même femme c'est
quoi votre secret elle a suivi le
premier commandement de la femme
adultère catholique tu aimeras ton
prochain comme le précédent
merci philippe bouvard avait été bien
aimable nom de rien à la politesse des
gens qui n'ont pas de triche on n'est
pas du tout pendant les heures de boulot